en 2019 la villa de los juegos
panamericanos de lima albergaba a miles
de deportistas ahora sirve de hospital
de emergencia para pacientes con el
coronavirus me paso no vaya al módulo de
aquí para recuperarme y ahora estoy en
mi casa
después de 33 días tras cerrarse los
juegos panamericanos el primero de
septiembre del año pasado los mil 96
apartamentos de la villa comenzaron a
cerrar acondicionados para ser vendidos
como viviendas pero al irrumpir la
pandemia en el país en marzo las
autoridades optaron por destinar cuatro
de las siete torres del complejo a la
atención de pacientes con kobe 19 en la
actualidad la vía tiene 1.300 camas
ocupadas de las 1730 que tiene de
capacidad sin embargo no presenta unidad
de cuidados intensivos por lo que los
pacientes más graves son derivados a
otros centros hospitalarios al límite
empezamos pensando en recibir pacientes
con cannon las minas sales y próximos a
irse a casa pero este cada vez se tan
complejo se tu paciente de complejos
están llegando acá en perú la letalidad
de los pacientes con corona virus en
unidades de cuidados intensivos ha
rondado el 50 por ciento el doble que en
el vecino chile sin embargo el hospital
de la villa panamericana ha perdido a
solo
53 pacientes entre los más de 12.000 que
ha tenido en estos meses y de alta ya se
han ido más de 10 mil 500 pacientes